i'm going to take you live now to kabul
where the taliban spokesman
has been giving a news conference uh
circumstances under which he would agree
to extending that date
we are not happy
following the deadline
the extension was unilateral
by the side
of the united states
it was a violation of the agreement
we want them to evacuate all foreign
nationals by the 31st of august
and we are not in favor of
allowing afghans to leave
[Music]
is
security
is
is
[Music]
um
about diplomatic missions those who are
still active which diplomatic missions
are they in which have left us but my
first point is about media i will
definitely look at this
i will also
look at the issue
there might be some small incidents and
we will definitely focus on it
as our
forces present uh in the area or for the
safety and security
and if there are
no security concepts in the area we will
remove our mujahiden from the area i'll
definitely pursue this
so if you could please focus on one
question one single question that would
give an opportunity for everyone to put
this question forward
please do call your uh
media
i am
well this is not related to our country
this is an external issue
well
we have
we have been
betrayed by so many people outside the
country we will talk about it at a
different time
my question is
so when are they going to stop their
activity and who
[Music]
we don't have such organizations active
in afghanistan we have a policy that we
will not allow anyone to use our
transport
we have specific rules in laws about it
and they won't be violated
a question in english today there was a
news item in washington post quoting
sources that the cia director has
secretly met mulab durgani brother
yesterday in kabul can you confirm these
reports and if so what was the purpose
of this meeting thank you
[Music]
we are meeting with different diplomatic
mission industries
there might be representatives from uh
um a u.s embassy before we are assuring
them to continue with their operation it
is in favor of
and interest of both sides to continue
to continue with their operations
[Music]
the line is very bad there is feedback
in the background
which includes
the embassy of the united states
they are here to they are meeting with
them to assure everyone
and to maintain
diplomatic relations
i will not
we will not confirm
we cannot confirm
that
has met with the cia director
spoke about the foreign of
external reporters
so what will happen to the internal
reporters
the problems
all right so if you're just joining us
you'll be listening there to um a news
conference being given by the taliban
spokesman in afghanistan
mujahid
he answered a number of questions there
he said that they had not agreed to an
extension of the deadline for evacuation
that evacuation as of now uh
scheduled to end on october 31st the
evacuation of of all uh foreign troops
and and and
afghans uh who who want to leave um but
they did not specify what would happen
if that um deadline uh was broken
there's also reports of um
the the accusations that there were
various accusations that were made
against the taliban of of uh rights
abuses and treatment of women um and he
also pushed back against that and uh
said that they that that would not
happen under the taliban leadership
let's go uh live now back to uh charles
stratford who is in kabul for us and um
so
uh
so charles we've
heard pretty much what you would expect
to hear from um a taliban leadership at
this point um and they were asked he was
asked as well about these reports of a
cia meeting
and whether that had actually happened
unfortunately there was a bit of
disruption there in our connection
um to that press conference when that
question was asked but if if if i heard
it correctly they did not confirm uh
whether that had happened uh or not
that's correct yes the taliban
spokesperson is saying that they could
not confirm whether that happened
whether that meeting between the cio
director and the new
um
head of the taliban actually happened
but um a press conference that covered a
whole range of issues um quickfire
questions from
the world's media that are here in kabul
i'll just read you through some of the
other comments that were made
as you said he said that
there's been no agreement made on the
extension of the deadline for the
evacuation that ongoing evacuation at
the airport
with mounting pressure on the u.s
administration
to put in for a bid on that on an
extension of that evacuation um the
taliban spokesperson said that uh the
media had started working he said that
uh every day the freedom of the media in
this country improves obviously a lot of
fear amongst media workers local media
workers
that many of whom have fled the country
already many of whom are at the airport
getting onto flights now
but he there the taliban spokesman
trying to allay those fears
he also said that um the crowd at the
airport can go home we guarantee their
security well the taliban have already
said that um
although they will not agree to any
extension of this deadline they say that
people who want to leave the country can
leave the country eventually if they
have the right paperwork
the right visas and they can get onto
commercial flights but of course nobody
knows when commercial flights will
restart
there was also a comment about the issue
of the panshir valley now the panchayat
valley as we've been reporting around
100 kilometers from here um there is
it's the last pocket of resistance if
you like
against the taliban
we know that the taliban have surrounded
the area or that's what they are
reporting
the group inside there in staunch
opposition to the taliban saying they
want guarantees that any uh new
government would be fully inclusive of
all ethnicities
and would be open and fair well
they have said that if that does not
happen they are prepared to fight for it
but as i say the spokesperson now saying
that they want that issue resolved
through dialogue
he also said that um
the taliban did not want foreign
embassies to close or stop work we've
assured them on security
and he called on the u.s not to
encourage afghan people to leave their
homeland uh describing it as a brain
drain on the country um and he said that
the taliban were trying to come up with
a procedure so women can return to work
so
as that press conference as i understand
continues um an example of the the kind
of pressure that the taliban are under
here um
under the world's spotlight um and very
interesting to hear some of those
comments of course the detractors
members of the international community
human rights uh workers um will say that
this is all talk um and so far you know
it's it's one thing for the time for the
kabul leadership the taliban to say
these things but they had to stick to
their commitments with the world
watching them the proof is in the
pudding so to speak
um so yeah as is a very comprehensive
press conference but uh a a lot
a long way to go yet
indeed for the moment charles stratford
live for us there in kabul uh and as
charles said they're likely to be much
more reaction uh to those uh comments
from the taliban leadership